quand on regarde le tour de france à la
tv difficile d'imaginer tout ce qui se
passe derrière
en l'espace d'une nuit l'avenue jean
mermoz s'est métamorphosé l'équipe
technique est arrivé à chartres à 2
heures du matin à six heures elles
étaient à pied d'oeuvre pour que tout
soit prêt à temps
le tour c'est comme je vais dire comme
un spectacle comme une mise en scène
donc le matin vous avez des chauffeurs
qui arrive qui pose qui installent des
camions avec les patients après ils
laissent les camions et c'est le ballet
de techniciens qui commença à prendre
possession de la zone le tour c'est 150
camions 65 km de câbles déployés sur la
ligne d'arrivée et de nombreux
techniciens mobilisés jour et nuit pour
satisfaire l'organisation le public et
les journalistes vous avez 100 109 télés
du monde entier
miss paris sportifs la taille à peine
plus épaisse qu'un cheveu vous avez 90
une radio commente en direct et toutes
les photos et tous les sons et toute la
date à l'informatique à la course des
tassements passe par cette fibre optique
donc réellement vous êtes dans le coeur
névralgique du tour de france un seul
fil déconnecté et c'est le noir complet
ni son ni l'image tout cela n'est qu'une
partie du travail de l'équipe technique
qui effectue allègrement quelques trois
mille trois cent cinquante kilomètres
sur l'épreuve soit l'équivalent de
quatre tours défensives